when we start to study electricity we
need to get an idea of what is current
and what is voltage and in to earlier
videos I talked about the idea of
current and voltage current and voltage
and what they meant and when we talked
about current it's easiest to describe
current when we talk about wires let's
say we have a copper wire we talked
about a copper wire and inside it was
there is electrons in it and they have a
negative charge we know they have a
negative charge and if we put a voltage
on them those electrons would move in
some direction like that so if I put a
plus voltage over here and a minus
voltage over here the electrons are
repelled by the minus voltage and
they're attracted to the positive
voltage that is called an electron
current
you
so talking about current in terms of
what's actually happening in inside a
wire make some sense it's easier to
understand current and that these
electrons are moving around and whenever
we talk about this we'll talk about it
specifically that there's an electron
current going on here now at the same
time what I said in that video and I'll
say again is the convention for
describing current is this this is
called the conventional current
direction
the convention we've had for hundreds of
years is that current is the direction
that a positive charge would move if
there was a positive charge there so
whenever we talk about current from now
on it'll always be conventional current
and in fact we don't even need to
mention conventional anymore
it's just current current is the
direction that positive charges would
move if we ever talk about electron
current then we'll use the word electron
current now as a reminder when we talked
about voltage this was built up by
analogy the analogy was to electrons
rolling down a mountaintop so here's our
mountain to remember this and I built a
battery or another voltage source like
this and we said that what a battery
does is it pumps out energetic electrons
and they go down a hill roll downhill
and go back into the back into the
positive terminal of the battery and
when we design circuits what we do is we
we put stuff in the way of this electron
on his path and this is where we build
our circuits so the the electron current
is going in this direction here down the
hill the conventional current direction
or the current direction is this way so
now I'm going to redraw my circuit in my
battery I'm going to flip the battery
around it until the positive terminal is
on the top and I'll put my circuit over
on the side over here like this there's
my circuit that I just built let's
connect those circuits up like that this
is the plus side of the battery this is
the minus side the plus side goes with
the long bar and the minus side goes
with the short bar there and the current
direction here the conventional current
direction or just plain current
direction is in that direction out of
the positive and back into the negative
from now on this is what we mean by
current and we know that the electrons
are in here they're heading around this
way like that but that's okay this is
the this is the nomenclature for
or conventional current or just plain
current